quando ero piccola mi faceva andare in
pescheria con mio nonno mio nonno mi
portava in giro con lui in pescheria e
compravamo facevamo la spesa melanzane
zucchine meloni mi raccontava dei
pescatori e poi insomma tornavamo a casa
con queste buste di spesa che avrebbero
potuto sfamare un esercito ogni tanto
capitava che passando tra un pescatore
l'altro mi si sporcassero le scarpette
questa cosa mi faceva arrabbiare un
sacco però mi che sono così tanto stare
con lui che me ne fregavo di contro con
la mia nonna sarà andavamo alla fiera di
catania giravamo gli stand cercando
gomitoli stoffa cerniere mi raccontava
di quando da piccolo faceva la sarta e
in entrambi i casi quando tornavo a casa
allestivo delle improbabili vetrine sul
letto o sul tavolo della cucina quindi
vendevo a seconda chiaramente della
location o cerniere vestiti e generi
alimentari
avevo registratore di cassa e un
blocchetto notes ero organizzatissima
purtroppo però nel senso che uscendo poi
cosa succede succede che non capisco
esattamente subito cosa voglio fare da
grande
quindi mi iscrivo all'università e do un
po di materia circa 15 però sento che
non è esattamente quello che voglio fare
decido quindi di abbandonare
l'università
mio padre non mi rivolge la parola per
un po di tempo e decido di fare tutti i
lavoretti di questo mondo faccio la
hostess e faccio la modella faccio la
commessa faccio la baby sitter e cercavo
di chiaramente mantenermi da sola e
raccogliere un po di soldi per partire
quindi la cosa che mi piaceva fare era
questa in uno dei viaggi che mi ha
particolarmente perché pensa che ognuno
di noi quando
già porta nel proprio cuore una foto
ricordo di una cosa che particolarmente
gli è piaciuta
in uno di questi viaggi a londra ho
portato nel mio cuore questo questa foto
questo ricordo di questi mercatini
meravigliosi allestiti benissimo
organizzatissimi colorati profumati
paradossalmente anche l'odore dell'olio
diventava un profumo gradevole
succede che poi finivano i soldi tornavo
a catania quando sono tornato ho deciso
di iniziare a lavorare nell'azienda
della mia famiglia
occupandomi di eventi e comunicazione
mi piace molto questo lavoro
raccolgo parecchie esperienze però
succede come per tutti liberi
professionisti
l'imprevisto in agguato quindi siamo
costretti a chiudere l'azienda per tutta
una serie di motivi economico finanziari
e mi ritrovo senza lavoro con un bimbo
piccolo è in realtà non avevo dove
pienamente mi trovavo di fronte un
fallimento non potevo però permettermi
di deprimermi e cosa ho fatto
ho raccolto tutte le mie idee tutti i
miei pensieri tutti i miei ricordi tutto
quello che sapevo fare anche quello che
non sapevo fare ho pensato che avrei
dovuto iniziare a doverlo fare è pensato
soprattutto che aveva un budget pari a
zero
a quel punto mettendo insieme tutte le
tutti questi pensieri mi è venuta l'idea
di andare indietro nel tempo ho pensato
che potevo realizzare market itinerante
un contenitore all'interno del quale ci
fosse l'artigianato la musica ci fosse
un'area food ci fossero i giochi per i
bambini ci fosse il ballo un luogo un
contesto dove la gente potesse arrivare
e divertirsi passare qualche ora
spensierata senza pensare a niente
così come facevo io quando giravo per i
mercatini a londra
succede che ci viene in mente
di organizzare il primo evento in un
posto speciale per me facciamo il primo
evento in pescheria
ed è così che mi ricordi di bambina
diventano il lavoro che iniziò a fare
inconsapevolmente questo format inizia a
fare rigenerazione urbana perché giriamo
tanti quartieri della città san berillo
civita quartieri che la gente non
concepisce come utilizzabili per un
evento
succede che questo format al successo e
un piace alla gente
succede che ci contattano tantissimi
comitati di persone di commercianti che
vogliono rianimare degli spazi nel
frattempo però penso che posso fare di
più non so perché ma sento che devo fare
qualcosa di più
un giorno mentre passeggiavo con mio
marito a londra in un food festival
bello divertente
penso però che potrei ad esempio fare in
modo che la città che amo che è londra
nella terra che amo che la sicilia
penso che posso fare qualcosa di più
cosa decide nella mia testa è
chiaramente le parlo con mio marito il
quale mi prende per parsa così ogni
volta io gli dico ho un'idea chi si
preoccupa
succede che decido di prendere la mia
terra e portarla a londra gli odori
colori sapori profumi le luminarie
carretti limoni pupi siciliani anche la
musique in a quella che magari nel delle
sagre decido di realizzare questa festa
di paese in una città metropolitana è
chiaro non avevo soldi per fare tutto
ciò
quindi dovevo cercarli ma soprattutto
dovevo iniziare diciamo da creare lo
staff ho iniziato a contattare delle
persone che siciliane perchè doveva
essere il requisito indispensabile e ho
chiesto loro ho raccontato loro di mio
progetto cercando di farli innamorare
perché è chiaro quando dobbiamo
presentare proporre un progetto a
qualcuno se non ne siamo innamorati non
possiamo pretendere che gli altri se ne
innamorino poiché lo accettino quindi
chiedo a queste persone di lavorare
gratis per me mi dicono di sì e iniziamo
facciamo un business plan cioè un piano
dicono mica di comunicazione iniziò a
fare questi viaggi infiniti a londra
iniziamo a girare per la sicilia
cerchiamo di mettere tutta la nostra
rete di contatti perché è chiaro ci
doveva pure aiutare qualcuno quindi
abbiamo iniziato a mettere io conosco
questo io conosco quell'altro chiamiamo
questo e succede che oggi dopo sette
anni e questa meravigliosa festa di
paese che ho sempre pensato nella mia
testa e un abbraccio è una tavola
infinita con 20 30 persone e quella
tavola che preparava mio nonno
ed oggi paradossalmente può sembrare
strano ma che quando si organizza un
evento tutti noi organizzatori abbiamo
sempre l'ansia da prestazione perché
potrebbe anche non arrivare nessuno
invece in questo format che abbiamo
creato con tantissimo amore e passione
così tanta da essere proprio percepita
perché la gente non se ne vuole andare
entra e rimane lì e noi non sappiamo a
volte come buttarla fuori ed è così che
adesso potremmo anche essere pronti ad
un'altra sfida per far sì che questo
evento possa chissà magari girare andare
in altri capitali europee girare il
mondo
perché è chiaro che quando si crede
veramente in qualcosa poi ad un certo
punto non ci si ferma più no quindi c'è
sempre quella voglia quell'emozione di
fare sempre un po un po di più questo
contenitore di sicilianità questi sapori
questi odori
questa la nostra cultura perché poi nel
frattempo cerchiamo sempre di avere
ospiti che possono raccontare questa
sicilia perché alla fine
molte volte appunto mi sono detta se io
qua londra ci sto benissimo però mi
piacerebbe che è bello mi piace sentire
quando penso di poter fare qualcosa per
la mia terra
oggi abbiamo ricevuto posso dire
tantissime richieste gli amici
conoscenti che stanno del nostro evento
e ci hanno scritto perché non lo fate
qua perché non lo fate ad amsterdam
perché non vi aspettiamo a berlino
quindi io dico ci vuole venire con noi
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]